let's talk about this hey what is going
on you - oh my god I'm so glad and maybe
a bit sad that I've lived long enough to
witness this if you don't know supreme
just released the best item on earth and
it sold out like a [ __ ] I'm
talking about people waited in line for
this product and guess what it was
drumroll please a [ __ ] brick
yes [ __ ] just a brick are you
it something somebody caffeine supreme
actually did a release and sold a red
brick - you dumb ass hype bees buy
anything out there mother the crazy [ __ ]
is right when it released people already
started selling it on eBay for 80
[ __ ] bucks what the [ __ ] now if you
don't know what supreme is supreme is
one of the hottest clothing brands out
there when it comes to street wear next
to go for God
[Music]
and yes they are notorious for being
able to sell anything with their brand
name on it and listen I understand that
when you're down for a brand you're down
to cut anything that it has but this one
is a little bit hard to understand you
dumb [ __ ] camp out to buy a
crusty brick let that sink in you but a
brick now I can thoroughly say this with
all of my heart and please take this
with a grain of salt if you bought the
brick and you weight it and camp outside
to buy it you're a [ __ ] loser
now when you wake up tomorrow morning
and you realize what you've done you can
honestly look at yourself in the mirror
and say I'm a dumbass the one thing I
have taking away from this though is
that supreme as a marketing genius and
you guys can get anybody to buy anything
but for those of you out there who are
trying to justify your purchase and make
other people understand why you bought
it let me just break something down for
you what I'm gonna do with that is it
for decorative purposes it's a Brit
[ __ ] if you wanted 100 and listen
I know what you're gonna say it's my
money why do you have to make me feel
bad powder shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] if you're stupid enough
to buy building material from a clothing
company that you stamp their name on it
and camp outside for this product you
but a brick people get clowned on for
stupid [ __ ] that they do on a regular
basis you are no different huh no David
it's art no [ __ ] put a F in front of it
it's fart I like how in today's society
when something is clearly just hot
garbage and a marketing ploy to get you
to buy anything your defense is always
it's art huh what was that David a brick
is a drug term so actually to represent
Street and lifestyle which is what
supreme is about David [ __ ] I could
attach any kind of meaning to anything
it doesn't make you smart today I'm
gonna sell you guys a bag of [ __ ]
because poop is manure and manure gives
food to the food that we eat which is
the source of life Nike just do it if
you bought that brick and any of your
friends looked at you and said leave
them because they're above the age of 20
and they have not passed the third grade
but in all seriousness if you bought
this brick for 30 bucks just because it
was gonna make you happy that I support
it a hundred percent but one thing I do
have an issue with this is that people
buy into luxury brands because of one
main thing and you probably will argue
about this with me but I'm glad to hear
your opinions on it I swear sometimes
people buy should just to show other
people that hey I have something that
you don't have which means that I'm
better than you not the case you dumb
[ __ ] just know that if you're an Asian
kid out there and you bought this brick
and you came home and you showed your
parents don't be mad at me when you're
sent back on the boat but what do you
guys think is the brick some [ __ ] or
is it a really good purchase
[Music]